You're married, but you have to leave your baby to go to work now
because it takes two incomes to run a home.
I wanna touch on programming that we receive from American news.
They create these little mantras that are told to us repeatedly,
like during 2020, this is the new normal.
The new normal. I heard it all the time.
I went to school for marketing.
I know what a mantra looks like
and I know what programming looks like.
They did the same thing with the whole,
it takes two incomes to run a household.
Are things expensive? Yes.
Is inflation out of control?
Yes. I work in financial advising.
I looked at hundreds of people's financial statements.
We practice what was called finance,
or holistic financial advising.
So we took an account every single aspect of their lives,
even your YouTube subscription.
Individual average income for Americans is about $56,000.
Even our line for poverty is much higher than that of other nations.
If I told you what my husband and I lived off of
after I had my first child
so that I could stay home,
you would be literally shook.
If you are married and wanna stay home with your child,
here are some things you can do.
I cloth diaper. I bought an entire pack off Amazon for $200,
and it will last him till he is 2 years old.
200 bucks, y'all.
And I used my MLM side hustle money for that.
There's almost nothing I buy for my kids
that is probably not off Facebook Marketplace.
All the necessities that we needed
we got from the first initial baby shower.
I birthed at home. This last birth cost us $3,000.
An average birth in a hospital without insurance is about $10,000.
If you have a C section, which is almost,
quite frankly, nowadays inevitable,
in a hospital, you're looking at about $50,000.
With complications, $100,000.
Now, just to be clear,
I birthed at home because of personal reasons
and I'm a huge naturopathic health fanatic
and I don't agree with what hospitals do for mothers.
That's completely different video.
But it was an added bonus of how incredibly affordable
affordable it was.
I just bought a $500 Bob double stroller off Facebook Marketplace
for 50 bucks and I hand sewed in the strap
so that both my children could fit in it.
My husband is about to shoot an Elk this weekend for 500 bucks
and that will feed us for the next year.
If you and your husband or just your husband
worked your entire lives and you paid all your taxes and dead gum it,
I completely support you getting your state's Medicaid.
All the benefits that are allotted to single mothers in most states
like Texas and New Mexico,
you have access to as a family
if you are running your household off a single income.
This is not forever, guys.
This is just to get your children from The smallest state of infancy
where they need and depend on you the most.
Until maybe you decide you go back to work
when they're two or three years old.
I breastfeed, so we didn't need formula.
I fast and eat an all carnivore diet,
which, by the way,
has doubled my milk supply.
I hand mill our own bread at home.
We only eat out on special occasions.
We have not traveled with the babies.
Yes, I had to say no to some weddings.
I had to say no to some out of state baby showers and graduation.
It's worth the sacrifice to me.
My husband had just started a business,
so we were at the very beginning stages of a business
where everything went into it.
And I told him, don't worry,
I will hunker down at home,
I will clip coupons. He does the grocery shopping for us,
so I don't even need my car like 90% of the time.
So there goes your gas.
If you are pregnant and your husband brings in about 39,000 a year,
that is the poverty threshold
to start receiving benefits from the state.
And do not feel guilty about this.
We have, quite frankly, sent billions to Ukraine,
billions to Israel, billions to the people coming across our borders.
If you worked, you paid into that
and you deserve it.
And it is just to get you through the beginning stages
of their infancy. There are options to stay home,
And live off a single income.
We are so brainwashed into thinking that we just can't do it
because the news stations and the media keep telling us, oh,
it takes two to run a household.
It takes two to run a household.
It, quite frankly,
from my experience and many other women that I know,
it is not always true. Now again,
I am talking to women that are married.
I have advice for single mothers.
Um, that would be a completely different video, though.
But do not limit yourself and what you think you are capable of doing
because of this programming we receive in our crap culture nowadays.
You wanna stay home with your baby's mama?
You do it. You can do it.
Think outside the box and get creative.
Talk to a holistic financial advisor.
I can hook you up with one for free.
You do not need two incomes to raise a family.